حمد لله على السلامه حمد لله على السلامه
مين زلزال الى اخر يعودون
لجوا الى تركيا منذ سنوات وحالت بينهم
الحدود
فرحه محمد برؤيه والده ربما هي الاولى منذ
يوم زلزل
يلتقي افراد العائله لكنه لقاء لا يخفف
الم التجربه التي مر بها
[موسيقى]
وافقنا العائله الى مخيم جنه القرى حيث
يقطن ذوهم
وفي المخيم اختلط فرح اللقاء بحزن الفقد
الخيمه للجده التي فجعت بابنها واحفادها
[موسيقى]
وبعد صمت طويل
يبدا الحديث عن الفاجعه
[موسيقى]
رد عليها الزلمه قالت له عمو ساعدنا حبان
بس قال لا يا مولانا
لكن رقيه وافتح المنيه بعد انتشالها حيه
من تحت الانقاض بساعات
وثق محمد بكاميرا جواله عمليات الانقاذ
يتحدث لاقربائه عن هول الكارثه مكان منظر
كتير كتير يعني ما بنوصف منظر يعني تخيل
البنايه سبع طوابق وواقع وبشر عم تصيح
عالم عايشه وعالم ميته
فما يطلع بايدينا غير البكي يا اخوي
والصياح لبعد الساعه ثمانيه بلشت بيهم
طلوع ضليت اذا ما بده شي ثلاث ساعات ونص
لحتى طالع حلو عبودي اول شي
ويا قلبي شام
وابو عبدو الله يرحمه
يعني فايتين ان احنا الطاقه لحتى نبين
الصوره بس فوقه كتير مو شوي
فوق السطح كامل
تصوير مباشر هاد دفنوا جميعهم في تركيا
ولم تحظى بلحظات وداع اخير
الحنون كويس
يا بعد قلبك كلشي المليح صفات
لا يكاد يخلو مخيم او بلده شمال غربي
سوريا من عائلات فقدت ابنائها او اقربائها
في تركيا
ليلم الزلزال شمل عائلات مفجوعه فرقتها
الحرب منذ سنوات الله يحفظكم
عائلات سوريه كانت تعيش في مناطق تركيا
منكوبه عادت الى اقربائها شمال غربي سوريا
يقولون ان المصابه اخف وطئه على نفوسهم
بين ذويهم اما عن مستقبلهم فهو مؤجل فجراح
الان ما زالت لم تلتئب
ادهم ابو الحسامه الجزيره